at this point you should be familiar
with personas and wireframes your next
task is to create at least one persona
and a user flow you can lay out your
persona on a piece of paper like this
split up into four quadrants your
persona should include the following
information a sketch of the person or a
picture of the person and their name
demographic information and any
behaviors that you think are relevant to
your product here you should include
demographic information that leads to
specific types of behaviors and here you
should put their pain points and their
needs try to differentiate personas
around pain points needs and their
behaviors by designing your product for
different behaviors or their different
pain points and needs you could really
target different users and finally
here's where your product comes into
play this is where you put all your
solutions for that user you can create
this persona using any tool of your
choice and I've included some additional
tools and examples which are linked in
the instructor notes you can rely on
user research here to help you out
remember the goal is to create something
quickly you can revisit this persona
that you create and the user flow when
you learn about design sprints in lesson
3 create a persona and include a user
flow that shows how a user would
complete a task and how the user would
interact in the main navigation or flows
of your product you can see one example
of this which is linked in the
instructor notes